okay what's going on guys uh this is rob
and the dream trailer for doctor strange
two just released today which by the way
i know a lot of you guys are waiting
like 30 minutes to an hour to try to get
tickets for doctor strange too i got
mine right off the bat like i was up at
like 7am and i immediately got tickets
the way that i did it check the website
for your local theater that's what i did
uh don't use like amc or fandango or
something like that because everybody's
using those but look up the website for
your local theater and see if you can
grab tickets that way that's how i got
mine uh but nonetheless this this
trailer was cool but it also got me
thinking i mean there's not a whole lot
of new footage but the new footage that
we get is pretty significant and pretty
impactful so here's the idea that i have
here and there is one major caveat to
this um that kind of stands out and just
sort of blows it out of the water is
maybe not necessarily being all that
credible but i want to talk about like
obviously the statement that scarlet
witch made where like her and doctor
strange basically say the same thing
right like you know every every night i
have the same dream and every day i have
the same nightmare or something along
those lines right so i want to talk
about these potential dream sequences
they're having because there's kind of a
similarity among them right so take for
example the idea of the dream versus the
idea of the nightmare so the dream as
you would expect just by the nature of
it being a dream is like a happy thing a
hopeful thing a good thing right
something along those lines and then
let's say of course the nightmare would
be like the dark and the evil thing now
there are scenes that we've gotten over
the course of the trailers that share
similarities so let's take for example
the the sequence that we get in the
trailer is only a momentary scene where
like the double doors open and then it
shows this giant staircase that leads up
into
seemingly oblivion right that that
coloring in that scene right there is
the exact same coloring that you get or
looks like the exact same coloring that
you get in the scene where dr strange is
talking to his evil counterpart but it
also looks like the same coloring that
you get when like everything is falling
apart right like everything is
dissolving like it all has that kind of
light blue faded tinge to it right so
imagine for example that those double
doors open up and doctor strange goes
through those doors
and that in turn when he gets up to the
top of that stairwell it's the city of
new york totally falling apart right
like dissolving falling to pieces you
guys you guys know the scene that i'm
talking about from the trailer
and so the last thing left is the
sanctum saint torm which is dissolving
and falling apart and like there's water
and everything everywhere so he goes in
there he goes up the stairs of the
sanctum sanctorum and that's when he
sees his evil counterpart right the one
that busts out the third eye in the most
recent trailer that's his nightmare
scene the scene that leads into that i'm
not entirely sure because what it looks
like with palmer right with her getting
married it looks like that's actually
happening now maybe that that is a real
world thing or maybe that is a dream
that he's experienced i mean i don't
know why he would dream that the love of
his life is marrying someone else and it
makes him happy right like i don't i i
wouldn't dream that
[Laughter]
that would be a nightmare sequence for
me
it'd be a horrible situation i would be
like god this is awful you know i
wouldn't be like the love of my life she
married someone else
yay like that was not what i would
that's not how i would
would do things right so christine
palmer marrying somebody else maybe
that's just like actually happening
right but focusing on that dark colored
hinge that dark colored hue on the uh on
the the screen in those sequences right
that's dr strange's nightmare sequence
now there's another nightmare sequence
he experiences which is the one that
looks like zombie strange and that would
explain why in the scene where he's like
climbing up the mountain or whatever it
is and like he's been turned into a
zombie that like he looks at this looks
at his hand and the look on his face is
like what in the hell is going on right
like i don't understand this like
someone's manipulating his dreams that's
his sequence right now we switch over to
the scarlet witch now one of the things
to point out here and this is where
things i think things are murkier with
her than it is with steven strange
because it's pretty straightforward with
the scarlet witch there's a bunch of
scenes that we get that are all like red
tinge right they have a red hue to them
you guys remember when the trailer
dropped and you had that scene where dr
strange was talking to wanda and there's
one scene where he's talking to her and
everything looks normal she's dressed
like a normal person she doesn't look
like the scarlet witch or anything and
the colors are all normal but then
there's that exact same scene seemingly
in that same moment when he's talking to
her and she looks like the scarlet witch
it's got a red hue but doctor strange's
clothes don't change right so maybe
that's not necessarily a nightmare
sequence maybe that is actually
happening but what i think may be going
on here with the scarlet witch is
there's what she thinks is happening and
there's what's actually happening that
in the scene from the trailer when dr
strange breaks out the third eye that's
the eye of agamotto now technically
speaking the eye of agamotto exists in a
couple different forms in the in the the
first doctor strange movie where he had
the amulet that contained the time stone
technically in the comics that contains
the eye of agamotto and whenever he uses
it it establishes his third eye and what
that does is it allows him to see
through illusions it allows him to see
what's actually going on there and so
potentially that could be what's
happening right that in that dream
sequence when his evil version busts out
the eye of agamotto it's casting aside
the illusion and it's showing what's
really going on that nightmare is
manipulating behind the scenes right so
at that point nightmare starts going
after scotty which maybe he's been going
after her the whole time i'm not
entirely sure i don't really know how he
fits in there assuming he even is in the
movie although in the trailer they said
nightmare so obviously that means
nightmare is in the movie
hope you guys can tell i'm just dripping
with sarcasm here but the thing about
this is that wanda has that moment where
she's sitting in front of her kids right
where like her kids are there and she's
like oh my god i found my kids right now
that could very well be her nightmare
sequence where the reality is her kids
are like you let us die mom
you
and like they turn evil right like and
then maybe she has to kill them and she
has to destroy them and that's why she's
got blood on the front of her or
something along those lines i have no
real idea right but whatever it is like
her seeing her kids that it's not real
and that's her nightmare her nightmare
is she finally finds her kids only for
them to like disappear or only for her
to have to destroy them or something
along those lines now the question has
to be asked if this is the case right i
feel like this the the dr strange aspect
or the doctor strange dream sequence
has more meat and potatoes to it than
the one with wanda because if every
nightmare sequence wanda has is clouded
in red right it's got a red tinge to it
then how do we explain the scene where
like she's fighting alongside wong and
you've got those monsters that the
either she's summoned or that are
cornering them or backing them into a
corner or whatever it is i don't really
know like how do you explain that you
know how do you explain the scene where
like wanda is the scarlet witch and
everything's red she's talking to doctor
strange but then at the same time she's
talking to him as her normal self and dr
strange's clothes don't change right
that perhaps there's what we see and
then there's what's actually going on or
what wanda really believes is going on
that kind of a thing i don't know it's
really really murky when it comes to her
side of things but a couple of the other
big things that go on here and these are
actually really really huge is i was
thinking about spiderman no way home and
how we watched that movie and then it
basically turned out that spider-man
homecoming far from home and no way home
we're basically just a trilogy origin
story and we didn't know that until aunt
may died and right before she did she
said with great power must come great
responsibility and it's like damn this
has all been an origin story like wow
okay kudos mcu this is kind of
mind-blowing right it's a thing that
none of us really suspected or maybe
some people did i didn't really suspect
it but uh but maybe that's what's going
on with doctor strange right because
right now if you look at the history of
stephen strange in the mcu there's a lot
of things that don't necessarily make
sense if he truly is the sorcerer
supreme number one steven strange and
the fight with thanos on titan that
fight would have been five seconds long
no way stephen strange with the full
totality of the power available to him
would have lost the thanos that never
would have happened right never would
have taken place and it doesn't matter
whether thanos had the infinity gauntlet
or not like it would no no that never
would have worked right there have been
ample times in old school doctor strange
stories right like the 60s and 70s when
you could have been like yeah doctor
strange was more powerful than the
infinity gauntlet right the guy was just
like a multiversal force of power it was
just crazy how how op he was the reason
why i say this is because in the trailer
we get our first real tangible look at
the book of the vishanti those you guys
who don't know what that means the book
of the vishanti is ridiculously
important to the doctor strange mythos
because like 80 of his power comes from
the book of the vishanti right so what
we could do here is we is assuming the
movie is following anything remotely
close to the counter the comic book
counterpart regarding like the source of
steven train uh strange's power how that
power works and so on and so forth if
the book of the vishanti is really
something that he hasn't discovered yet
and that it's really something that
exists out there and that power is
something he's never tapped into then
what it would mean is that doctor
strange is 20 as powerful as he will
become right his power will amplify
four times over what it is right now and
that'll be just ridiculously op now
that's assuming that's the case right
that's assuming it was actually that's
what's actually going on something else
that's really interesting too that i've
also been mulling over is one of the
things doctor strange tells peter parker
and spider-man no way home is the
multiverse is something they know
virtually nothing about and so what this
would indicate to me is that doctor
strange is not traveling the multiverse
of his own volition he's not leaving
anything that is actually america chavez
who's showing him everything like she's
the one giving him the tour of the
multiverse she's the one showing him
where everything's at because he doesn't
know where anything's at because he's
never really traveled the multiverse
before outside of presumably that one
time when the ancient one sent his mind
throughout the multiverse and doctor
strange won when he was questioning
whether or not she was legit and that's
it but like outside of that america
chavez is showing him everything and
where he's like okay we need more power
like i need i need i need like more
power or something she's like well
there's this book that kind of sits out
there in this place this citadel that
looks like it was destroyed uh let's go
check it out and like it's the book of
the vashanti i don't know i'm kind of
throwing out crazy ideas here the
reality is i mean maybe it really is a
nightmare manipulating things behind the
scenes right but like why like what
benefit is there because here's the
thing when it comes to nightmare
nightmare's power is not predicated on
the power of the person who is
experiencing a nightmare the reality
here is that the scarlet witch
experiencing a nightmare or experiencing
a dream and nightmare feeding off of
that is no different than like some girl
named jane who works as like a typist in
some legal firm somewhere and like is
going out with her friends friday night
to get a few drinks and maybe some guy
will ask her out
it's no different than like just some
plain jane girl who drinks starbucks in
the morning what makes a difference in
the in terms of how much of that energy
nightmare can feed off of is the potency
of the dream how intense that dream is
right so if jane has this just crazy
intense dream about some guy she met at
a bar with a spanish accent that was
just so sexy that she just has like this
crazy physically intimate dream if that
dream is more potent than the dream that
scarlet witch has then nightmare will
feed off more energy from jane than he
will from the scarlet witch uh so that's
kind of how that works more so than that
the more people that are sleeping at any
particular point in time the more power
nightmare has so in marvel overture for
example there was a point where
nightmare put the entire earth's
population to sleep and then fed off all
that energy right it was an eternal
slumber non-stop dreams until nightmare
was presumably defeated but until that
point in time nightmare's power was so
extreme he basically killed he defeated
and killed galactus the celestials
eternity infinity the living tribunal no
one could stop him because his power was
basically limitless it was just an
unlimited source of power from billions
of people who were all dreaming in
perpetuity and that was it but it was
just it was nuts you know so so the real
question here if this really is
nightmare operating behind the scenes
unless they're changing things up and
they're saying that like nightmares
power can be expanded upon if the person
who whose dreams he's manipulating are
that powerful then he can literally
channel their own power for himself
which is entirely possible the mcu plays
by its own rules unless they're doing
that it would make more sense if there
was some point in the trailer where it's
like the world is stuck in a state of
slumber and nobody knows how to wake
them up then like that would be a
surefire guarantee nightmares in this
movie like that's exactly how you would
know but if there's ever a point over
the course of these trailers if there's
ever a line in these trailers where it
indicates the world has fallen asleep
and like doctor strange doesn't know how
to wake them up right that's when you
know nightmare is involved but until
that point unless they've changed them
up there doesn't really seem to be any
indication of why nightmare would be
involved here outside of scarlet witch
just saying the word nightmare and the
word nightmare being mentioned a few
times over the course of the trailers
i'm not saying he's not in it right i
mean it seems fairly on the nose in this
recent trailer right like nightmare like
it's almost like she said like the way
that she says it in the trailer it's
almost like she's telling someone
nightmare is the one behind all this
right it's just kind of how it feels
when she says it so again i don't know
i'm just kind of throwing out some crazy
ideas here but let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section right
let me know what you guys think about
all this either way i am excited for
this movie i can't wait to see it but
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace